je vous le disais en titre la facture de
vos ordures ménagères risque de monter
en flèche dans les prochaines années
la taxe sur l'enfouissement des déchets
va en effet passer de 18 à 65 euros la
tonne d'ici 2025
or dans le domaine du traitement des
déchets l'indre et loire est en retard
pire ces deux sites d'enfouissement sont
condamnés à la fermeture notamment celui
de chanceaux-près-loches voyez ce
reportage d'hélène chapelet chaque jour
30 à 40 camions franchissent les grilles
du centre d'enfouissement technique de
chanceaux près loches
c'est là qu'une bonne partie des ordures
ménagères de l'indre-et-loire finissent
leur vie
compact et entouré de membres and
plastics et enseveli sous de grandes
quantités de terre une solution qui
n'est plus satisfaisante
d'ailleurs ce centre n'accueillera plus
de déchets après le 31 décembre 2000 23
ou partiront alors les dix mille tonnes
de poubelles grises collectées sur la
communauté de communes loge sud touraine
personne ne le sait encore
les collectivités locales du département
où devront renoncer à nouveau appel
d'offres et trouver des solutions sans
doute hors département peut-être région
peut-être même plus loin et donc il va
falloir faire beaucoup plus de
kilomètres aux déchets pour les traiter
les trois principaux sites qui
accueillent les déchets ménagers de
l'indre et loire vont progressivement
fermé et pour l'instant aucune étude n'a
été lancée pour envisager de les
remplacer
alors à qui la faute à la région nous
répondons c'est l'entité qui doit
décliner la loi de transition
énergétique sur le territoire et elle
n'aurait pas prévu de nouvelles
ouvertures de sites en indre et loire
ce qui nous empêche aujourd'hui c'est le
plan régional qui nous dit non vous
n'aurez pas de nouvelles l'exutoire en
indre et loire puisque globalement au
niveau de la région
ça suffit malheureusement s'il nous faut
conduire nos ordures ménagères à l'autre
bout de la région même pas vraiment à
l'autre bout mais ne serait-ce que à 100
km ou plus on a quand même un dispositif
qui est incohérent il faut qu'on arrive
à une solution beaucoup plus local
il va donc falloir agir vite pour ne pas
faire encore plus voyager nos poubelles
sur la roue
d'autant plus que la masse des déchets
produits ne baisse toujours pas depuis
de confinement les emballages
individuels et les déchets des repas en
livraison explose